Want to make a few clarifications
on the video on the marriage penalty.
The first is to point out
a minor arithmetic error
is that when I calculated
the amount of taxes
to pay on this bracket,
so the 15% of the increment
between 17,850 and 72,500,
that is actually 8,198
and since that was 8,198
this right over here
would have been $10 higher.
So it's 43,466.
It doesn't change at all the ideas.
It's actually a small amount of money
in the whole context of things,
but I just wanted to get the
math a little bit more correct,
but you still see that you
have a marriage penalty.
But the more important
thing that I want to clarify
is I saw in the discussion on
the marriage penalty videos,
some people saying,
"Okay, fine. If it costs more
to file married jointly,"
"well, why don't those people
just opt to file as individuals"
"and then they'd just have
to pay this right over here"
"and they could essentially opt
out of the marriage penalty."
And I want to clarify is
that is not an option.
If you are married, you
don't use the pure individual
tax schedule. You don't
use this over here.
Instead, if you are married
but you want to file separate,
you use the married filing
separate tax schedule
and you see in this, that this
is ... this is exactly ...
it's different ... It's the same
as the individual tax schedule
up until in these first three brackets,
but then as we go above that bracket,
it gets into the higher tax rates
faster than the individual ones
and it does it ... If you
look at these brackets here,
you see that they're
exactly half the brackets
of the married filing jointly
and that's because, at least
for this couple right over here,
that's making identical incomes,
they're going to pay
the exact same amount,
taking into account some roundoff error,
for married filing separate as
they are married filing jointly.
And we can go through that exercise.
So each of them had
100,000 in taxable income
and in Couple A example that I gave
and so the first 10 per or the first 8,925
they're going to pay 10%.
That's just rounding. That's 890 ... 893,
actually I could even say 892.5
if I want. 892.5 is 10% of that.
Then on the next bracket,
they're going to pay 15%.
So that is $4,099 ... $4,099.
And then on the next bracket,
they're going to pay 25%.
So 25% of this right over here,
actually I think I rounded
this number, but we'll take
into consideration a little
round off error. So 9, 238
and then they're going to pay
28% ... 28% on the
increment ... The increment
above 73,200. So they each
have 100,000 ... 1,2,3
in taxable income. Subtract
73,000, 200 from that
and they're paying 28%
on it and this gets us,
each of them having to spend 20
or have to pay 21,733.5 in taxes.
If we combine the two for
both parties to the couple,
we have 43,467 ... 43,467
which is essentially the same
as if they would have had to file jointly,
the difference between the 6 or the 7
that's just because of some of
the round off right over here,
but they had to pay the
functionally equivalent tax rate.
So just to be clear, if you are
married you either have to do
married filing jointly,
married filing separate.
There's also a separate head of household,
but you do not have the option
of filing under an individual,
so you can't just opt out
of the marriage penalty,
if it happens to exist for the scenario
that you happen to fall into.